bom dia
antes de contar um pouquinho do meu
trabalho
comentários sobre a minha trajetória
eu sou graduado pela unisinos formei em
2007 e o intervalo de ingresso e
desfecho do meu curso de letras
português é teve uma duração de dez anos
entre 97 e sair em 2007
durante esse tempo todo eu participei de
inúmeras oficinas de teatro com o
professor joão barata vieira o bira e
esse processo híbrido na minha formação
entre as letras e as artes cênicas têm
me ajudado muito na minha atuação como
professor eu vou contar cinco caminhos
que eu utilizo para aproximar o aluno de
ensino médio e fundamental também mas o
trabalho que eu vou mostrar que é de que
o desenvolveu com um médio aproximar a
tentar aproximar o adolescente ao
universo da leitura e da escrita
nós estamos num período em que a leitura
ela é ela não tá nada próximo ao aluno
aluno ele impõe barreiras impõe
resistência e como consequência disso
eles demonstram inúmeras dificuldades em
escrever então nós temos esse círculo
vicioso entre um aluno distanciado
apartado da leitura e num momento em que
ele tem que desenvolver a sua ideia e se
expressar pela escrita
a escrita é deficitário então eu tenho
cinco caminhos entre leitura e escrita
eu inicio do méxico que disse sobre o
que vocês nada querem aprender essa é a
sensação que nós temos quando nós
entramos numa sala de aula e na proposta
da leitura prolifera é a indústria do
resumo
então nós estamos nesse embate nós temos
que
segui alternativas pra vencer essa
indústria do resumo da obra literária
aí eu tenho algumas propostas que eu
penso que são importantes
eu acredito que o aluno ele não não devo
estar distanciado da leitura e tem que
desenvolver sua leitura de uma maneira
em que ele seja protagonista daquilo que
ele está fazendo
como é que eu faço a aproximação do
aluno da escrita e da leitura e buscando
pelo protagonismo eu tento fazer com que
os dois façam parte de uma mesma
história que o aluno esteja tão inserido
dentro da leitura que pra ele ler é
possa ser alguma coisa prazerosa
então eu costumo dizer que pra isso pra
colocar esse aluno no universo da
leitura eu uso um pleonasmo pleonasmo
entrar pra dentro
entrar para dentro do livro significa o
protagonismo que eu busco através das
minhas ações que eu vou contar um
pouquinho pra vocês é uma das atividades
que eu desenvolvo é também em parceria
com o grupo pibid unisinos do qual eu
sou supervisor é a organização de um
festival de cinema que nós chamamos lá
no colégio de curta plangg que nós
fizemos eu distribuo vários contos
várias obras os alunos lêem de forma
individual ou em grupos eles fazem
escolhas fazem análises debatem o que
estão lendo brigam muitas vezes
aí a gente trabalha o roteiro de cinema
e nós temos lá adiante um objetivo que é
a inserção desse aluno no mundo
audiovisual e ele estará lendo
mas aquela leitura da qual ele é
protagonista vai se tornar um produto
mais ali na frente
então de todas essas essas
particularidades desde as brigas que
eles promovem porque daí eles começam a
interagir de tal forma com o texto que
eles têm as ideias que querem fazer com
que elas aconteçam e toda essa discussão
de tudo isso dessa seleção de textos
desses fragmentos desses estilhaços
todos que vão acontecendo pelo caminho
nasce o festival que é o curta planta
o curta plangg nós temos premiações em
várias categorias e nós oportunizamos
aos alunos né a conquista de troféus no
caso vocês estão vendo ali o que quito
que nós compramos réplicas e nós
oferecemos a eles e aí vocês poderão ver
nós temos nosso festival no saguão da
escola e têm direito até ao tapete
vermelho para que as celebridades possam
cruzar
então é um momento de puro protagonismo
depois de cerca de dois três meses de
trabalho então é um trabalho muito
complexo para que realmente o meu
pleonasmo possa ter feito o aluno
definitivamente entrou pra dentro do
texto então ele consegue compreender
aquilo que está lendo ele não vai mais
estar distanciado daquele texto que ele
muitas vezes não conseguia entender
então as categorias ator atriz cenário
figurino roteiro júri popular e direção
então todas essas categorias elas também
auxiliam a fazer com que o aluno
compreenda aquilo que ele leu
mas daí nós chegamos a um outro problema
que é a escrita a escrita nós
desenvolvemos o projeto imagem e palavra
nós recorremos a imagem do fotógrafo
sebastião salgado e unimos várias
disciplinas língua portuguesa literatura
e sociologia história e geografia
então todas essas fotos de sebastião
salgado elas servem como provocação ao
aluno que ele consiga olhar para uma
situação de exclusão de miséria consegui
olhar e ver não passar indiferente por
aquilo ali
só que como eu vou pedir pra um aluno e
inscrever-se agora a pouco eu disse que
ele tem deficiências
bom então toda essa união de disciplinas
fazem com que o aluno tenha subsídios
para escrever ao longo de dois meses
a história vai falar da origem das
favelas sociologia vai falar de exclusão
é literatura vai ler vai ler textos
poéticos de cunho social geografia traça
o mapa da miséria no mundo e são
subsídios que a gente vai montando com
toda essa a união com as fotos de
sebastião salgado então uma palavra
importante para esse trabalho é dar
subsídios ao aluno para quem possa
escrever e ter argumentos é coerente ao
longo do tempo eo último trabalho que
ele vai fazer é o gênero texto
argumentativo em português no qual ele
traz toda essa bagagem desenvolvida
pelas outras disciplinas transposição
literária é uma atividade que o uso
tanto pra conto quanto pra poesia
às vezes o aluno chega e diz eu sei o
que eu quero dizer
mas eu não sei como escrever então
especialmente na poesia
eu trabalho com um jogo de sombras e nós
colocamos todas essas idéias subjetivas
às quais ele não consegue traduzir eu
solicito a eles que largue para sombras
então todas essas imagens todos os
versos todas as idéias que eles querem
passar a transmitir
eles criam imagens projetadas na sombra
ea gente vai tentando unir imagem e
palavra e o subjetivo ele acaba sendo
revelado ele concretiza em imagens
projetadas nas sombras que depois são
fotografadas é montado um powerpoint
eles enviam pra mim por e mail
aí nós marcamos determinada data
realizamos uma apresentação uma troca de
ideias e daí essa compreensão é
partilhada é construída também a partir
das imagens que eles projetaram é esse
exemplo que eu trouxe é de um trabalho
que eu realizei este ano com um do
fernando pessoa e eles no início acharam
um é bem difícil assim compreender mas
ao final desse processo o fernando
pessoa
ele tinha o seu subjetivo revelado
trabalhei também nessa realidade de
sombras a uma adaptação para a
neoleitores do clássico romeu e julieta
depois nós assistimos ao filme é o
casamento de romeu e julieta e nós
fizemos uma montagem e também a partir
dessa montagem nós adaptamos alguns
trouxeram aqui pra o cenário gaúcho e
também trabalhamos discutimos toda essa
questão da obra
então acho que a experimentação eu acho
que essa questão das sombras pelo fato
do aluno consegue contracenar com o
texto não apenas mais lê ele promove uma
experimentação o aluno constrói a sua
própria gramacho jia uma outra
dramaturgia
um outro trabalho que também nós
desenvolvemos na escola
nós temos uma rede de professores
parceiros é e o grupo pib de também
estar junto nesse trabalho é um projeto
chamado literatura além da morte
nós reunimos várias disciplinas ao longo
de alguns meses e o final desse projeto
é uma produção de um caderno de
atividades com vários temas né entorno
vários assuntos em torno do do tema
morte
o desfecho desse trabalho nós viemos a
porto alegre nos dois cemitérios são
miguel e almas e da santa casa e lá nós
conseguimos abordar vários assuntos
trabalhados em aula longo do tempo em
que o período foi desenvolvido para
citar um exemplo nós visitamos o túmulo
do teixeirinha cantamos a música
querência amada
procuramos o túmulo da maria degolada
lenda urbana de porto alegre
nós abordamos a obra canibais dos
famosos crimes da rua do arvoredo a
partir do da obra do david coimbra
nós atravessamos a rua então vamos ao
cemitério são miguel e almas
nós distribuímos aos alunos em frente ao
túmulo do mário quintana em jeans é uma
das paixões do poeta e ali nós
construímos um sarau em frente ao túmulo
dele
nós cantamos músicas em frente ao túmulo
do psi rodrigues e fizemos uma
performance diante da sepultura do erico
verissimo
no início do projeto quando nós
colocávamos que seria uma visita ao
cemitério tinha muito medo muita repulsa
as pessoas não não tinham gosto por isso
por esse caráter inusitado no final do
projeto eles ficaram bastante
satisfeitos porque quebra essa essa
realidade de estar só dentro da sala de
aula só no interior do muro da escola e
uma outra atividade é livro didático nem
sempre os alunos gostam de abordar
então eu busco alternativas pra que essa
abordagem seja diferente então eu pego
emprestado do jornalismo
as tags que são as palavras-chave a
palavra principal de um texto eu faço eu
vasculho um capítulo que em determinado
momento eu quero trabalhar e eu
distribui para os alunos que eles têm
por exemplo que procurar 10 tags
então ao invés de nós fazemos a leitura
do modo tradicional responder às
questões
eles são lançados diante do livro
didático e são colocados a decifrar as
tags que eu previamente havia construído
então acredito que isso faz com que o
aluno pesquisa e diante do livro
didático que é uma ferramenta
tradicional né
mas a gente tenta buscar um caminho
alternativo para dar um uma outra cor
uma outra tonalidade a esse trabalho
então pelas palavras que eles vão
buscando eles pés em uma rede de
entendimento e eles pesquisam diante de
um trabalho é diferenciado em relação ao
livro didático
então acredito que todas essas palavras
a motivação subsídios e experimentação
curiosidade pesquisa gera o protagonismo
que gera interesse o interesse que gera
leitura escrita uma tradição que gera
inovação e uma inovação que gera
tradição esse é o caminho que eu tento
trabalhar com os alunos para trazer eles
mas próximos ao universo da leitura
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]